we already knew a bit about the
divisions first three expansions
underground survival and last stand but
we've just learned of ubisoft's plans
for releasing them I'm Tony and this is
sure to be a divisive gamespot news
update and not just because of my
terrible puns underground and survival
are coming to the Xbox one first 30 days
before the ps4 and PC last stand however
will release simultaneously across all
platforms this winter Ubisoft also has
several free updates planned for the
game all of which will release for those
three platforms simultaneously the
updates will add new endgame activities
and dark zone content so you shouldn't
run out of stuff to do in the division
anytime soon the updates are free but
you can grab all three expansions with
the divisions $40 season pass they're
also included with the gold and
collector's editions of the game the
division launches worldwide tomorrow
march eight to keep up with all the post
release news keep those sites aimed at
gamespot